sometime in the next year the BBC
governor's not the government or MPs
will decide whether or not the over 75 s
in this country will continue to get
their television licences for nothing
nearly four and a half million homes
don't pay the hundred and fifty pound
fee as anyone over 75 is exempt even if
they live with younger adults until now
the government covered the cost the
money going directly from the social
security budget to the BBC but from next
year BBC governors will decide whether
the system continues this is plainly
ridiculous how are the BBC governors
qualified to take this decision they're
not elected politicians but simply
well-meaning members of a quango
personally I hope they scrap free TV
licences for over 75 and find a way of
paying for only the poorest old people
in truth the BBC governess should never
have been put in this position in the
first place we elect politicians to sort
these things out and this is a cop out
by the government who didn't want to
take to be seen to take an unpopular
decision every week I gave my Twitter
right you're gonna ya know every week I
go my twist at this is a different point
I'm gonna make and I'm not gonna make
the facts I'm not gonna make the point
that it's all right for you to say they
should be scrapped because you can
afford it I'm not gonna at that point I
know I'm not gonna make the make the
fact that the point that you always want
older one the older anyone to pay more
tax and stuff because you can afford it
I'm not gonna make that point either
every single week I got my Twitter
before the show and I say it's the
people what is it you would like me to
debate on the pledge this week do you
know the one topic that comes up week
after week after week after week
it's the BBC licence fee week after week
after week after week people say to me
please will you debate the fact that the
BBC licence needs to be scrapped yeah
they contact me every week of my life to
ask me to debate that so what I would
say is first of all I do agree with you
that it's a cop out by the government
for not having their the the balls
whatever you want to call it to make
this decision themselves so I agree with
you on that but I would say that if
you're gonna look at what we're gonna do
with this license fee you probably ought
to raise the upper level and look at
whether or not we still need that and
whether or not that is still the way
because when you look at actually I
think the license fee is gonna cost them
seven hundred twenty five million pounds
to subsidize this which is a fifth of
their budget BBC yeah yeah the BBC and
actually the reason it's a fifth of
their budgets because their budgets are
getting stretched on things like very
expensive dramas to compete with Amazon
Netflix and people like that and one
might be sitting at home shouting at the
screen going hang on a minute
why should I be paying for the BBC II to
create very expensive drama series and
that's where I shall end my point
the BBC should be ashamed that this is
even a matter for debate
there is absolutely no justification to
take TV away from one of the most
vulnerable and Nord sections of society
TV is a lifeline to many old people from
the outside would it it's it's you know
it stops them from being lonely it stops
them from being isolated and for them to
eat the baby seat prides itself on our
being a champion for civilised values
for a responsibility towards
marginalised group but they want to
pickpocket pensioners and it's a fallacy
that all pensioners these days are
well-off because they're not there the
BBC's own stats say 1.9 million
pensioners are living in poverty and and
a million and a half of them are living
solely on the state pension alone that's
all they've got and that's that's seven
grand a year Greg so if you take away
150 quid from them a year that means
showing which is why I said let's look
and find a way of paying for this to the
post okay so you mean how much does that
cost
how much does means-testing will do this
tax system is all sorts of no but I mean
how much of the 725 million as they get
back yes well on your figures about half
I suspect that half can I just pick up
on what Carol said and you know Carol
again I didn't what's going on the show
today really keep agreeing people I'd
never agree with Carol I totally totally
agree with everything you said so this
is a statement from Caroline Abraham's
who's a charity director Age UK well she
says is one in four
people for one-in-four older people the
TV is their main form of companionship
the question for the BBC is therefore
how they intend to fulfill the
responsibilities they have taken on as
regards to the TV licence concession for
over for the over 75 s who are amongst
the most loyal and committed viewers and
listeners the majority of of whom live
on only modest incomes and if you look
at that they're saying what is this
almost four and a half million people
who watch the BBC are over 75 that's
such a huge chunk of their audience I
have a choice do i watch my old mate
great guy beaten up by four of us or do
I come and said I'm just gonna join in
what did you say did you ever doubt it
the House of Commons library let's take
a look at this as Michel said this is
the amount of money raised from the
licence three try 3.8 billion pounds can
I suggest 3.8 billion per can I suggest
and in the days and I remind everybody
you ran the place yeah not that long ago
I don't know but I don't know whether
you're aware of the Netflix's and the
Amazons and all that time television you
know this better than I do Greg is
delivered in such a different way now as
Michele says the whole idea of a licence
fee I remember once when I was working
in America I described it as Americans
and they were made so this they said so
even if you never drive on the freeways
make ways you only ever use the side
roads you still have to have a license
and I said yeah
even if you only ever watch sky or you
only watch ITV dad ever used to it's
done it's antiquated Michelle's right
you can't switch it off like that
because I appreciate there are funding
issues and we we all want parts of the
Beeb to survive but make the whole
license fees a done deal I think that's
a different discussion whether whether a
long time I mean every time whatever
looked at the license we come up with a
say look it's not a satisfactory system
but it's better than any other I'm not
sure I agree I think there are ways of
funding the BBC that aren't both via a
license fee but that's that's not that's
not the specific that's not the specific
issue I'm talking about here what I'm
talking about is that sometime in the
next year you are asking a bunch of BBC
governors to decide whether or not we
should continue to subsidize the oldest
and some reported speaking
they're gonna not do it because they
want to save the money they haven't had
a paid no I think what they were a
person I think they will do is they'll
find a way of trying to support the
poorest pensioners disgustin but when
you do you really think that when you're
75 all your awesome time you should get
a fee like yes I've been paid long
enough older people consume more
services and you know why they do
because they've been paying into the
system the new Greg this is the new the
new Greg that the director general of
the BBC Lord halt less isn't what he
says we've got on the one hand inflation
in the content market on the one hand
our audience is expecting us to do
different things and you know their
expectations are going up on the other
hand real hardship among pensioners this
is a very very difficult issue and Isis
suspect you know it's one of the reasons
why we have to think about it and the
government said over to you is because
it's a very very hard thing to work
through and I know the board will take
that very very seriously
should have said there was and the
government should never have given me
sauce now when they tried to do it
before his predecessor said and the
chairman both said if you do this will
resign and the government backed off
they accepted it and I think was a
mistake because he threatened to resign
who he should have set eyes on like Marc
Thompson did before him because actually
they they've left the governors in a
ridiculous position and the government
are the governors do they're there to
make sure there's a good BBC and then
this is the this decision is a decision
for politicians and if it's unpopular
because they've got to do it
that's the politicians fool except if
they if they did take this away from
pensioners that it would make a mockery
of their their their role as a public so
I think you could I think you could well
subsidize the poorest pensioners I think
all the evidence that is you can find
shows that actually the number of poor
pensioners today compared with 20 years
ago
sure so subsidize those two million
don't subsidize four and a half million
I don't know about you grab but I'm
looking forward to my freebies I'm
looking forward to my free life I'm just
gonna summarize this debate he wants us
just appear more tax and yet less things
for free just in case you missed that of
what he said